في السودان الصراع متوسط بين المكونين
العسكريين
ايام المره يعيشها السودانيون الذين
تطلعوا لعهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
حياه العشرات تحولت لماساه حقيقيه بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني صراع تلو اخر عمق
الازمه وزاد من حده التملل والاستياء
ملامح الحزن والاسى خيمت على وجه ادريس
حسن الذي فقد ابن اخيه عندما اخترقت قذيفه
النافذه المنزل ادت لمقتله على سريره
[موسيقى]
على الاجزال الليله فقدناه
والمرحوم دخل ده ما في سريره
القصف تسبب بحروق لوالده الضحيه التي صدمت
من هول الحادثه
[موسيقى]
وجعت راسي
السرير
[موسيقى]
الحياه المدنيه توقفت في السودان
مناطق سكنيه مكتظه بالسكان ومتخامه
بالرصاص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات